well what part of your essence part of a
well-regulated militia you don't
actually believe this [ __ ]
this video is being made by popular
request as we've already debunked some
of the biggest central myths regarding
the Second Amendment like the fact that
it was only created for muskets here the
idea of the gun show loophole here the
idea that proposed gun control
legislation would curb gun crime here
and even this very subject of
well-regulated militia versus the rights
of private citizens to own arms here
there you are to the point of this video
is to specifically provide as much
context as possible regarding the rights
for private citizens to bear arms and
we're going to keep this short
roni I don't have all day to bark at you
so I'm gonna make this short and sweet
again we've previously addressed the
idea of the Second Amendment being for a
well-regulated militia only
well-regulated militia , the right of
the people well-regulated men an
organized militia outside of government
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms so that they could form a militia
we're done but it's a moot point if
there is more context if there are some
corroborating documents regarding the
Second Amendment as it relates to
private citizens from the founding
fathers good thing there's plenty so you
don't have to take my word for it the
Constitution shall never be construed to
prevent the people of the United States
who are feasible citizens from keeping
their own arm the Constitution of most
of our states and of the United States
assert that all power is inherent in the
people that they may exercise it by
themselves that is their right and duty
to be at all times armed if the
representatives of the people betray
their constituents there is then no
recourse left but in the exertion of
that original right of self-defense the
laws that forbid the carrying of arms
are laws of such a nature they disarm
only those who are neither inclined nor
determined to commit crimes such laws
make things worse for the assaulted and
better for the assailants they serve
rather to encourage than to prevent
homicides for an unarmed man may be
attacked with greater confidence
armed man I asked sir what is the
militia it is the whole people to
disarms of people is the best and most
effectual way to enslave them no free
man shall ever be debarred the use of
armed and you can find plenty more quote
after quote of the founding fathers
expressly outlining the second amendment
is meant for the people because who
could form a militia if not the people
that's why they had to be armed they
just fought a tyrannical government what
you think they wrote this that the
people could petition a tyrannical
government to ask them for weapons to
fight them are you mental if the
founding fathers knew that the kind of
that the kind of lethality that we now
have existed or was going to exist in
the world what would have happened to
the wording of the Second Amendment well
you've got that half right I never
expected you all being so stupid the
beauty of the Second Amendment is that
when taken at face value it's incredibly
clear when you add more context more
historical documents it becomes even
more clear despite what clickbait
youtubers may tell you the founding
fathers weren't ignorant morons who
wrote the Second Amendment with no idea
that the world could possibly change
they wrote it expressly for the people
because they were brilliant and
understood just that so the only
argument left at this point and granted
some leftists make it openly is that you
don't like the Second Amendment and you
want to do away with it that you think
we'd be safer and that's the progressive
thing to do at least we're having an
honest argument you want to disarm the
populace because you think it's safer on
my side I'd argue
you
oh hi there subscribe it's so convenient
you can do it by just clicking a button
on this digital witchcraft straight
everything's more convenient nowadays
you have semi-automatic weapons this
show means in our house it flushes
you've got a baby there